[Music]
all right so hello and welcome to
tactics time
fortunately done it's going to be here
this week so I'll be taking over and
this week we're going to be going over
situations when it's actually better to
not make a queen with your pawn and you
want to make some other piece instead
like a knight or a bishop or rook even
so for example in this position if white
were to play routes to g8 and black were
to take on g8 what should white play
here
yeah and what piece do you want to make
okay so what happens when the pawn gets
to the end of the board yes so what do
you want to turn it into oh oh right so
what happens if you make a queen here
it's blacks turn right so it can black
play anything
yeah so black can't play anything so
this is what's called stalemate so when
the Queen is covering all of these
squares the pawn is covering the square
and the King is covering these two this
King can't move so the game would end in
a draw so what you have to do instead is
make a different piece so for example a
knight or a bishop would work whatever
look work now it's still the same
stalemate so yeah we have to make a
knight or a bishop so I think a bishops
best so King to be eight king to d6 and
if black tries to cover the queening
square we can simply check them away and
make it clean all right so that's one of
the times when you're going to want to
look out and actually promote with
something other than a queen is when
your opponent has no moves and you don't
want to end the game in the draw so
we're going to look real quick at
another endgame example and this time
we're going to promote to a knight or a
bishop or rook for different reasons so
black has plenty of moves but the
problem is he also has a queen so what
we need to do is find a way to promote
this pawn
so how could white try to get that pawn
promoted yep okay and if I take it what
with check alright but the problem is
can you win Queen and Bishop versus
Queen yeah I don't think so it's not
very easy at all in fact I think it's
technically a draw
yes so we need something better than C 8
equals Queen yes the dutour equals rook
well that's even worse right yeah so
black just steps out of the way and then
he's up a queen right right
so after Bishop d5 check blacks only
move is to go to a7 and now of course we
don't promote to a queen when we would
have the same endgame but we make a
knight then after the King moves away we
can take the Queen
now I'm sure yeah I'm sure everyone here
knows this checkmate by heart yeah but
this is actually the only way for white
to play here because we try something
slow
for example playing Bishop d5 here to
prepare okay you just get checked
forever
and you can never really get out of it
you might end up getting forked
somewhere and it'd be terrible for
everyone so R if the a is the only way
to win so what happens on earth to a if
black tries to play away like this yeah
you still just make a knight or a queen
even is probably enough and you fork the
king and queen
yeah so that's another situation we want
to make a night when you can distract
blacks pieces or your opponent's pieces
and then end up making a fork when you
clean or night
all right so now we're actually going to
look at a game so this is an end game
Karpov had against uh someone no one's
ever heard of in 1962 so here as you can
see black is up one pawn on the Kings
side and has a bishop for the night so
blacks definitely trying to press for a
win here so Karpov started by playing h5
so he did this because he wants to get
his pawn going down the board all right
so Wyatt made a waiting move and now
black continued with this plan after
King to d4 eyeing some of these squares
so Knight to d3 trying to cover up his
weaknesses so Bishop d6 moving out of
the out of the threat after Knight - f -
Bishop e3 93 Karpov finally plays g4 so
its plan is very difficult to stop he's
just going to play g1 and make a queen
so white takes because you want to trade
pawns when you're trying to draw in a
minor piece endgame especially so nice
to be - just waiting Bishop f4 Knight to
d3 again stepping out of the threat
Bishop to d6 King to d2 and now Karpov
decides to push so white decided to be
kind of tricky and instead of playing
something like ninety one to just defend
against the pawn push he instead played
a four so now what Karpov did actually
isn't the best move
what Karpov did is push the pawn so how
can white try to punish this
because it looks like he's going to
clean by force and you can't really stop
it it's white smooth yet
well there's no stalemate because you
have these pawns over here so you'll
always have some legal moves yes so what
happens after Knight to e1 if black
makes a queen yeah you have the fork so
this would be a huge mistake because
white could play here
black would move away and Y could take
the Queen and now it's just an easy draw
but Karpov noticed this so what do you
think he played instead what's the only
piece a knight can't fork another night
that's right
so night orgy 1 equals Knight defending
the f3 square playing around the fork
so then Karpov obviously went on got his
knight into the game and after a little
bit of trying he managed to trade off
the Knights and his opponent resigned
here because like a takes b4 and Bishop
takes before both easily winning for
black especially since this is a dark
square so the bishop can easily help the
pawn promote so what could Karpov have
done to avoid this do you guys think
from this position
obviously it was still winning but
there's something a lot more convincing
what could Karpov have done to avoid
having to make a night and play out that
endgame
yeah that's actually right so what
happens if white takes the pawn well you
could take the pawn and that's still
winning but there's something even
better
not quite because the Knights covering
it
well actually yet the night when I'd
actually be able to take on before but I
think white could bring his king closer
to the pawn
yeah
well yes let's look at that for a second
so if white takes this night white can't
stop this pond from running but uh yeah
so what if white plays King - II - well
this is also probably easily winning but
others the line even better than than
this maybe alright I'll just give you as
the answer so it's just playing the same
move as we tried before playing c4 so
what was the point now what if what if
white plays Knight e1 with the same idea
well yeah he could but now he has
another option so yeah
bishop before check is the idea so after
king - e - you can take the knight and
now you make a queen so yeah Karpov I
don't think actually missed this idea I
think he just felt like making a knight
and having a bit of fun but no it was
actually a standard tournament in July
being in 1962 but yeah his opponent was
not a very famous person I don't think
he has any other recorded games in
history besides this one but so yeah
that was Karpov under promotion alright
now we're going to one that some of you
might have already seen and this
promotion wasn't forced and it didn't
turn out to be very fun either
so I'm gonna I'm going to call this one
a failure so this is a game card
Nakamura recently played in the Paris
Grantchester
so most of you are probably thinking
well it looks like black might even be
better because those pawns cards are
down the board but this end game is
actually just dead drawn and neither
side really has any chance any chances
here
the reason is after white or black makes
a queen with check white is forced to
take it and then black can just take
this
on and then it's an easy draw alright
but if I were to tell you the black
actually lost this game and what do you
think he played worked f3 not quite
you didn't make an obvious obvious
blender he decided that he was just
going to promote to a knight because he
didn't think it mattered he thought all
whites just going to take it and we're
going to transpose into the same thing
it'll just be a bit of fun
I'll make at night however white has
this move or at the f2 check
so now what's wrong with playing King to
g3
because if white just takes here and
black just takes here you get the same
thing but why it has a better move here
right the rook to f3 check and if the
King moves away
yeah that's right you don't take the
night you actually trade rooks and the
points is after age six the night cannot
catch this pawn and white would be
winning so this means black has to come
down the board the g1 which allows white
to take the night with check
so now after the King moves away Y can
simply check again and defend his pawn
so actually Nakamura hadn't blown the
game yet he just he had just played a
little inaccurately
and given his opponent an extra pawn but
I imagine he was pretty flustered after
missing Erick to FCU check and rekt xf1
to check so he played some very
inaccurate moves but this game is
actually pretty easily drawn and the
drawing idea is to do nothing which is
sometimes difficult especially in a
blitz game when you have no time on your
clock but if black actually plays King
to h2 and then King beige one and then
King to h2 and then King Dage one and
then King beige to White has no winning
tries because as soon as you move the
rook away from this pawn for example
directive f2 check King to h1 you have
to come right back to defend it and if
you try to get your king in well you
just can't because my work is covering
all of the squares on this rank so for
example if work f3 that just loses this
pawn so there's just no chances for
white unfortunately for Nakamura
let me flip over the notation here and
get back to the game he played some very
bad moves so he played Rick to a 3 here
which what is this a lot wait to do well
sure he can check but yeah it lets them
get a pawn one square farther down the
board so now he has to come back or else
the pawn will keep pushing and we get
the same position except with the pawn
is farther down the board so Nelson's
still a draw you still have this idea of
king 2 h2 to h1 to h2 to h1 and white
can't really do anything about it
but unfortunately for Nakamura you
played King to h2 so that's
came to F 2 and now we played root 2 H 4
what is this a lot wait
the work was doing a very important job
on h3 what does it no longer doing yeah
so now white takes the space and he's
getting closer to its pong so Nakamoto
plays King h3 which is fine and after
rook here he's forced into playing some
moves he doesn't want to play for
example if you play rook to h5 just
trying to pass first of all why could
come off the board and secondly rook to
g1 threaten sir to h1 with checkmate and
also some other things as well King -
age - I think would have been his best
tribe when after King - g1 you simply
have to check and player cage for den
and this is another draw but instead
yeah he missed all this stuff to be fair
he was playing on three second increment
so he had three seconds to actually
physically make his move and hit his
clock so he was basically playing
instantly but sorry yet delay so he
didn't get any time back he had to make
every move in under three seconds so
instead he played or cage wrote to a4
and what is this below yeah you just
pushed the phone again and after it to
h4 this is actually a losing position by
this point the game continued route to
g7 were caged 6 km for cage for king at
5-4 h5 q g6 and now the king helps the
pond get to the end of the board and
black resigned here because of King to
g8 and pawn to h8
so sometimes sometimes especially when
you have a lot of time on your clock
it's not good to be fancy right even a
bishop here would have been better
because it checks the king and forces
white to take
Nakamura wasn't giving any interviews
that day yeah I think he preferred to be
left alone after that game but uh yeah
he was just trying to be fancy and play
of fun yeah all right so that game was
certainly tragic for Nakamura all right
moving along I'm going to show you guys
kind of a more fun puzzle that would
never happen in a real game but
illustrates some nice ideas so it's
White's a move here and white is trying
to checkmate blacks King so this is just
a fun puzzle what do you think whites
should play first of all yes I know it's
the big problem the problem is none of
blacks pieces can move right this is his
only move so black is only gonna have
one move and then he's in stalemate
again we have to find a way to prevent
that from happening
it's White's turn one yes white to move
and win the game
and there's no trick one for the pieces
are go nope white spawns are going this
way black spawns are going this way
that's it
so very counterintuitive idea but once
you see it you'll be amazed that you can
think of it before
right so if you just try to play for
example King G here yeah but now the
King can't move the pawn covers that
square so we need something else it
might be you well to remember the theme
of this lecture it's all about under
promotion okay and after that's right so
the only move that gives black illegal
moves so black has to take it is only
legal over and now you promote another
pawn and what do you play here yeah you
have to promote to a knight again so
black places only legal move and now you
play okay so now you play Knight to g6
forcing black to fake and then here yeah
you make another night that's right
Aditya all right and then what do you
play here yeah that's right Knight to c6
giving up the knight
so push the pawn black pushes and now
what do you play yeah you make a night
with checkmate so that's just a fun
puzzle but I thought I'd share with you
guys because I really enjoy it so yeah
that's why it's the only way to win all
of those promotion different
my meter all right sure all right so
back to a more realistic scenario we're
going to look at an end game that often
pops up in a lot of games a lot of
grandmaster games has been seen in this
is just one example so here is white two
moose and so white is going to try to
promote this pawn so he plays King to f7
black realizes he can't stop this pond
from promoting so it gives up his rook
and white takes so my question to you is
can white stop this pawn from promoting
no did you count yeah well what the real
problem is is this King is too far away
but what happens when the King is just a
little bit too far away from the pawn is
white can force a knight versus or again
game all right so if you can imagine
white brings is clean closer because
this rook can't stop this pawn all on
its own
if you play something like rook to c7
sorry here if you play something like
earth to c7 he was trying to stop the
pawn black will simply move away he
won't step in front of the pawn because
that gives white time to bring his King
in but if he just steps away if you come
here he'll step back and if you come
here he'll step away and you can't
really stop this pawn from pushing down
the board with the riffle on so you
definitely need the King to come in in
order to in order to stop the pawn so
can you defy black pushes pawn white
gives this check in order to get his
King closer so King does see two King at
c4 b2 and now from here
how can you guys prevent black from
making a queen at least
without sacrificing your rook all right
so you check with the rook I'll step
down push the king where
right so what happens on King c3 and
then if black makes a queen now you
don't win the Queen you win the game
that's right so if you make the Queen
this is simply checkmate and black can't
move away because light will take the
pawn why can't black can't move this way
because light will take the pawn so what
it's like I have to play yeah why it why
the night working cuz it's check that's
right
so black gives check to White's King and
saves the game because the night versus
rook when the king of the night are
right next to each other usually is a
draw I don't want to go into like
specifics of this because I mean even
I'd not sure on all the technicalities
but as long as the night mode King can
stay close to each other it's usually a
draw so they played on for a few more
moves white did is best to drive the
King and night away but black simply
keeps them working together and here
white agreed to a draw but yeah if you
don't know this know this idea and
you're playing a blitz game for example
after King to c3 you might make a
terrible mistake
but it's important to keep in mind that
you can't make a Queen here because of
this check map that comes a lot more
often than you realize but uh yeah it's
not too important because still the draw
for black even though white can make up
this little threat which came to c3 but
definitely one of the most common under
promotions that you'll see alright and
now for an opening trap alright so if
you can imagine black is going to
promote to a knight on move seven
alright so that sounds pretty absurd but
let's see how it happens so it comes out
of the Queen's pawn game the Queen's
Gambit and actually the Albin counter
gambit is what this is named so striking
in the center immediately trying to
break down white D pawn so white accepts
the pawn and now blacks point
to his play as he gets to play d4
preventing this Knight from coming to a
natural square and grabbing substantial
space so one of the most natural moves
when your opponent pushing upon deep
into your camp is to try to get rid of
it right so how can White try to get rid
of this pawn just right away you three
looks good enough
well you've fallen into the same trap
that white made alright so the way white
normally continues is simply playing
Knight to f3 and after some more moves
like Knight to c6 for example white
being ket owes and sometimes black
castles clean side and white plays
something like Queen to b3 or Knight 2 D
2 and you just get a normal game but the
instead here falling for a trap white
plays pawn to e3 so we're on move four
and remember Lex making a knight on move
seven so we better you better hurry up
so what happens if black just takes on
e3 yeah that's right you just trade off
Queens and take back to Bishop and
White's position is amazing why it's
probably close to winning with this
extra pawn and this lead in development
so black can't do that so black needs
something better instead which Chuck
yeah the bishop check so the bishop
checks on b4 and white wants to defend
with tempo so we can maintain this
threat on the pawn so he plays Bishop to
d2 attacking your bishop so now is where
the tactics begin what do you think
black can play here move five we've only
got a couple more moves to make our
Knight
take what well you could take the bishop
but then we get something similar to to
the other line right because if you take
here I can simply take with my queen or
trade Queens and take with my up pawn
and why it's totally fine we need
something more active yeah Ken pon takes
pawn that's right so you hung your
bishops no not Queen takes Queen we
don't want to trade Queen and then after
pawn takes pawn white can simply develop
and he's totally fine
this was kind of actually a common
tactic in a few different openings
sometimes with the so yeah hon takes up
to check so sometimes it's a bishop
doing this tactic and I think it comes
up in Sicilians when you're not careful
enough but why can't white take this
pawn what happens if white takes here it
drops the Queen right so we have this
threat on the Queen and we have this
threat on the King
so what's why it's only reasonable move
here to try to keep the Queen yet King
de to soak into e2 and now black has a
problem because if black ticks here and
just makes a queen white will simply
recapture and you have one two three
pieces - one two three pieces and sorry
white won't simply recapture white will
probably trade Queens and then recapture
so we need something a little bit faster
than taking on g1 and making a queen
right so you make a knight and this is
check well now it forces white to
capture right and it doesn't exactly
force wait to capture but for the sake
of the trap will will show this line so
it takes g1 and now what was the point
of forcing white to recapture instead of
taking on da it first
what has white allowed
Bishop
right so Bishop g4 check scaring the
king and queen so after the king moves
away white will simply lose the Queen so
because of this it's actually better for
white to decline taking the night and
play King to e1 here but after a few
more moves get played such as Queen to
h4 check when you can't play g3 because
Queen to e4 will fork York and rook so
you have to play something like King to
d2 here and simply something like Knight
to c6 and the very few times since has
been played over the board white just
gets checkmated within 20 moves so it's
a it's definitely not aligned you want
to fall into but what would happen as I
said if black takes here and makes a
queen
how does white escape from this Bishop
g4 idea
so you trade off the Queen before
recapturing and now there's no skewer on
d1 so the king can simply move away so
right here the only move that maintains
an advantage is taking the night with
check by promoting to a knight so the
moral of the story is don't play e3 here
very very bad and your opponent will be
very joyful if you see that was played
all right so moving along I think I have
one more game for you guys and we're
actually going to go through the whole
game for this because it is interesting
and there are a lot of attacking ideas
and this is tactics time after all so it
starts off with a slog white plays Nexus
III 5 6 9 f6 Knight f3 and we get the
chap and then go slob I think so why our
blacks idea here is you wants to play b5
very early and lock up the Queen side
before white can do anything like
attacking a week's e6 pawn attacking
week b7 pawn he wants to avoid all of
that so white plays III simply defending
this pawn because if he were to play it
some other moves such as Bishop f4 black
is probably threatening to take this and
then play b5 and holding onto this pawn
against all odds ah a 4 is probably no
k-member before before this point yeah
oh you mean a 4 here it's probably ok
it's a little strange to leave the
square so open for example like often
times a night ends up coming here
through a6 after like a 5 is played and
yeah I mean a 4 I think it might be a
move but blacks still under no
obligation to take this pawn so maybe
it's a little a little strange but I
think III is more common so then black
strikes back
against c4 upon by playing b5 so now
white decides he's going to gain some
space and prevent any pieces from coming
to these squares for the rest of the
game but the drawback of this is that
it's very difficult to break open the
queenside now so White's going to have
to find play over here so black decides
to fianchetto is bishops since it can no
longer come to this diagonal because
this Colin is in the way so white
develops the bishop and now black plays
an interesting move so what do you think
the break black is playing for is going
to be like is going to try to make a
pawn break somewhere we need to figure
out where it's going to be and how he's
going to get it in
I'm talking about a pawn break so yeah
developing your pieces is always fine
die buted d7 is a fine move but uh
usually an opening there are certain
pawn breaks you want to look after so
here White's most advanced pawn is on c5
the blacks probably looking to undermine
it somehow so yeah what you want to do
is eventually play this move to gain
yourself some space and if white tries
to take it he'll leave this on very weak
so you can't play e5 now so black plays
an interesting idea which trades off a
piece that controls e5 for a piece that
can never control e5 what do you think
that idea might be AB Bishop to g4 so
this Bishop black decided was not going
to be very good with all of these pawns
sitting on light squares and this knight
controlling the pivotal e5 square is a
good enough piece to trade it off for
black decided so this is the cabinent go
Slav and it is the Sheva and go after
like a 6 and b5 these ideas are what you
know too so white plays h3 and Bishop
takes f3 following through the plan and
now white can actually make a decision
here so it would make a lot of sense to
take with the Queen because it just
develops your own piece but so you can
also take with the pawn and the point is
first of all it gives you this nice GG
file and while it does kind of shatter
your pawn structure and leave these
pawns more weak than they were before it
allows white to do something very
important and that is after Bishop g7 or
Knight B to d7 either one makes sense
and you can play f4 so what does this
move do so yeah it's controlling the e5
square even more than before so black
still has gotten rid of this bishops but
now instead of for control of the five
square it instead chariot self off to
weaken White's pawn structure but I
think that
scored pretty well for white in the past
and this is the main idea but fiddler
decided he wanted to take with the Queen
so he did black continued Bishop to g7
just developing and now white decided to
strike quickly with g4 so wife's idea is
to find play on the Kings side by
playing h4 h5 trying to open this up and
open up his rooks so black decided a now
is the time for his pawn break because
you needed to play quickly since white
was being so aggressive
so black plays e5 so how do you think
white responded to this do you think
white took here or played something else
as right he didn't take so white
probably didn't like the way uh this
line looked after something like night s
to d7 attacking both of whites weak
fawns and opening up this Bishop and so
he instead opted for Queen to g3
because what happens if white just
ignores it and played something like b4
yeah he gets worked on e4 attacking to
pieces so he can't allow that
so instead white moves his queen out of
the way and black continued with Knight
F to d7 again trying to open up this
Bishop take on d4 and get some play so
white played Knight to e2 just defending
the pawn keep they're keeping everything
close for the moment and here black
plays Queen to e7 again just supporting
this pawn preparing an eventually for if
he so desires so white continues with
his development just gets castled and
black plays h5 so the reason black
played this move is because he was
concerned with this pawn break which
would be kind of strong for white and
also he wanted some more space and to
try to get activity of his own for his
rook so we did play the committal h5
which maybe maybe better with just to
beat a castle and just to face the
oncoming pawn storm the brave face but
the black was feeling ambitious so he he
went for h5 and white decided that he
would just defend his pawn with f3
simple enough and here black plays
Knight to f8 so again he's trying to
open up this bishop by playing Knight to
e6 and putting even more pressure on to
this pawn
right so this is what wife's thinking as
well whites thinking all right
my opponents playing a slow maneuvering
game in a position where that should not
be slow and we should be playing with
some serious pace so what do you think
white played here to try to open things
up and use his lead in development which
move be three a four you mean yeah so I
think white actually led with a four
which the point is now you can play
Bishop d2 and develop the tempo and now
that these traditional moves on the
Queen side are taken care of now white
really wants to blast things open so how
can all right first of all black King is
here right flexing is right here so when
the King is in the center you want to
open the center especially since you
have these nice rooks coming over and
bearing down these files the only thing
that's stopping you is that these pawns
are all in the way so how can you try to
open up these pawns for your rook
change exchange on e5 hold on I don't
think so now you wanna yeah you play e4
so this is very combative move because
it's leaving behind the D pawn which
blacks all ideas he wants to weaken it
and attack it but in exchange White's
going to open things up and put his rook
on the e-file so black has to be very
careful here and he he decides that he
must trade on e4 because he probably
didn't like he probably didn't like this
line when I he simply doesn't have
enough pieces to defend his King and
like f4 f5 will come if you try to play
Knight to g6 and like that forward to d5
is coming and it's very very bad so
rather than being greedy black simply
took on e4 white your capture with the
bishop because he still wants this pawn
break available and so black continues
with this plan kakdi for preparing to
open the bishop and also puts pressure
on d5 so again white's thinking i really
need to open the center or else my pawns
are just going to be weak i need to use
my leading development so how do you
think you forced the center open
right so white didn't want to take care
because then his own pawns start getting
in the way after something like Queen to
c5 for example just attacking here and
also with Czech so picking there is off
the table and I think actually played
one more preparatory move getting played
rook to a to e1 first and then after h4
Queen eight f2 and castles now his pawn
break comes so what do you think he
played to break the position yeah that's
right
so f4 attacking the e5 pawn and forcing
black to do something about it so black
plays pawn to d4 and now white made a
mistake that led to his downfall which
is he decided to leave this on behind so
best for him would have just simply
would have been to play something like 9
2 c1 went after Knight to d3 this pawn
break is still coming and black doesn't
have time to take care because the
bishop takes c6 with the double attack
on the Queen and the rook so no this is
a standard time control so obviously
black wouldn't take here if white were
to play this line and would play
something maybe rook to c8 here just
defending the pawn maybe trying to get
developed and leaving this pawn behind
but instead white decided that he needed
to go right now so he played pawn to f5
it's very very aggressive but it's not
as good as night to c1 because after
black takes this pawn which he now can
because it's nice in the way so there's
no discoveries white simply doesn't have
enough you have to retreat the bishop
first of all because it's attacked and
then after d3 you have to move your
night because of the tax and after Queen
to b6 suddenly suddenly your own squares
aren't feeling so safe but a white
continue pressing he played bishop
a to creating some threats so he's
pinning this pawn to the king which
further would weaken so light squares so
later on White's going to try to take
here and maybe take here and get in
through these light squares so black
played a move you're probably thinking
about yeah black is winning according to
stockfish at least I think it's one
minus two almost I can pull it up if you
like oh yeah - - for even ya whites why
it's totally busted
but the I'll sorry I just lost the
notation let me bring that back up okay
so yeah so what do you think black
played here
b3 well yeah the night covers enough
nothing's being threatened right now
precise foot the threats are soon to
come time to get the night out well
that's that's pretty slow you need to
play with some more pace so what black
chose is Bishop to b4 when white is
forced to play his next move because
otherwise he'd lose the Queen the Bishop
to e3 is forced and here I continue I
continues with Knight to f4 pushing the
Queen away so White's most natural move
and the movie chose is just to take on
h4 and now he's beginning to have threat
to the zone like f6 and Queen h6 with
the checkmate or taking on g6 and then
bring your rook ins and now he doesn't
really because uh well first of all as
Queens attacks so we have to do
something about it and playing something
like Queen to g2 just simply isn't
enough in positions like these when both
sides are being checkmated very often
your only choice is to try to race your
opponent because you can't hold up
against all these weak squares in this
war ah he could play Queen to f4 this
doesn't lose any material immediately
but maybe after takes right it takes the
black have a tactic here right and you
don't even have to take the bishop you
can actually just play d2 right away
because this is a pin so white will lose
like a full rook maybe a little bit more
here at the very least
yeah the worst pawn structure for sure
is very relevant but so yeah white
pretty much has to take on h4 and go for
his own threats instead of trying to cut
his losses and deal with what's going on
at home but the black continues with g5
which is actually the only move that
keeps the edge it's very important that
g5 gets played to prevent F takes G six
opening up this rook kind of yeah
because g5 doesn't come to mind very
easily but it is necessary to keep the
trucks blocked in behind this pawn or
else white White's threats actually
become very real and they start to work
so g5 was played and actually I can show
a line here I think I inputted it so the
most natural move of course is just d2
torquing these two pieces trying to
immediately but then after F takes G six
Knight to g5 is forced because otherwise
this is a checkmate and you don't really
have time to take over here because I
will take on d4 and now what happens if
you try to Queen yet
checkmate on h8 so black needs to deal
with these threats so Knight to g5 is
pretty much forced and after that white
can simply take on f7 Knight takes f7
and what do you think white can play
here involves a few sneaky tactics that
you might not notice at first glance
month not Bishop takes Knight but he
actually takes advantage of this pen
somehow
not quite wrote a tonight because if
you're too slow you always have to be
thinking about this but yeah just Queen
to g5 giving check yeah
and the reason the thing you manage to
kind of the night can't capture alveoli
because of the pen so after Bishop to g7
which is pretty much forced you can't
play something like King to h7 or King
to h8 because they'll be taking here or
giving check here slow Bishop to g7 and
white continues with just taking the
pawn and now if we count material why
it's technically ahead upon but the more
relevant feature is that blacks king is
very weak so here black has to go in for
this perpetual check he has simply
nothing better so this is why g5 was
very very important because that takes
you six is a very strong move that black
had to contend with
so g5 secures the win after Queen to h5
now black and changes with d2 and
there's one more one more trick you have
to watch out for it here the white plays
f6 black plays Queen takes f6 so what
happens if we take this Queen obviously
right so if he takes over here
we don't recapture so we don't recapture
because of this check again taking
advantage of this bishop and then
probably white should try to solve his
problems here somehow it's kind of
difficult but uh that's definitely not
accurate to take with the night so what
we do instead is simply if you're on
this Intermezzo and we take this work
with check and white doesn't have enough
time to do any of these threats because
of this Queen City we just lose here
after like this move and it probably
Queen check here and night shift here
picking up the Queen so white can't take
the Queen so instead he plays so sorry
so instead he plays Bishop take me for
trying to remove this pieces from all
these pins so black plays Queen takes d4
white plays King takes g13 to g2 and now
how does black convert the game only one
move ones here that's right so what
happens if we promote to a queen here
sorry I didn't mean to make a rook but
what happens if we mix clean here
right so despite like having two queens
he can't defend his King enough so after
Bishop f7 York f7 Queen f7 conveyed
shade is the only move Queen to f8 keen
age seven is the only move or at the f7
came to g6 obviously Quinta g7 we would
just take it
so King g6 scream H or Queen g8 p h6 and
you're actually checkmated so you don't
have time to make a queen and you
definitely don't have time to try to
defend like this so what you have to do
is make it night and then faces this so
they're simply resigned so what do you
think happens if white tries to avoid
stepping into this check by playing King
to h1
oh sorry we'll start with King be H to
can black somehow force white step into
the into the idea so yeah this is the
right idea
you definitely want to play some check
before white can get in but maybe each
so yet so d6 is the rate square so
what's the idea after king - h1 yeah the
night forks became the Queen and then
this is the more subtle idea but if the
King comes back to g1 where do we check
yeah we check on g3 and after king - h1
oh well you don't want to hang this
tactic because this would just be a draw
so we need to play a move with the check
a D - what were you saying
yeah night - f - so what's the idea
after white takes it yeah you make a
queen so now that the rook has moved off
the back rank you can promote with check
and that would end the game so Sigler
was probably quite happy with this
position here because or maybe not quite
happy maybe he was probably a little
nervous like the rest of us but I
imagine he might have not seen the
brilliance promotion to a knight because
otherwise he'd have a very good position
and black would have to go in for this
perpetual check line that I showed well
he he didn't miss it here but maybe
maybe back here he was thinking you know
maybe maybe this is better for me well I
mean white what White's attack is
nothing to laugh at because black had to
find a couple only moves to keep his
initiative going and to not crack under
the pressure but yet this all started
going wrong when white was too impatient
here with f5 he definitely should have
played 992 c1 in the 93 and then f5 and
blacks position is actually quite hard
to play if all these things get played
so there any questions about the game
any questions about promoting all right
well thank you guys for watching hope
you enjoyed
[Music]